it was meant to be a great leveler
infecting a prince to hospital Porter's
but Co vid 19 is killing one group
disproportionately in our community and
within our Health Service Sky News
analysis found that 75 percent of all
health care staff that have died from
kovat 19 are from a black Asian and
minority ethnic background stark numbers
like this that NHS England to advise all
trusts to risk assess their pame staff
at the end of April all we've lived and
breathed for the past 3-4 months has
been covered but two months on from that
instruction NHS staff like this
consultant and many of his colleagues
have still not been formally risk
assessed to be honest - they are
massively fuming and I suspect that a
lot of my colleagues will be absolutely
furious as well this is an
institutionally and track 3 racist
organization and certain groups of
people are not prioritized and they're
not really the same if this was an
illness that affected preferentially
Caucasians it would be a very different
story
in fact Sky News can reveal that many
vulnerable non-white NHS staff right
across the country have still not been
risk assessed
despite guidance from the very top we
contacted 221 NHS Trust in England to
find out if they risk assess all of
their B AME staff as recommended a
hundred and forty nine of those trusts
came back to us but from that group only
23 percent said they had risk assess all
of their B AME staff but one former
hospital CEO says the task is too big
and could lead to huge logistical issues
I don't know a CEO of a trust who does
not take this seriously and does not
want to do it but because of the numbers
involved in the complexity of doing it
it's a mammoth task and it will take
time just this week in a letter NHS
bosses urged trusts to complete risk
assessments within a month and today the
chief people officer apologized to those
who haven't been assessed the FOI
results
are disappointing so let's be clear that
this is protecting our staff is the
number one priority of the NHS it's the
number one priority of any employer
because there's not only a legal
requirement to provide health and safety
at work there's also the moral
requirement to do that
we are expecting a second wave of kovat
19 and questions remain whether some of
the most vulnerable people tasked with
protecting our lives will be fully
assessed to protect layers in summary
sheets can use